C
[음악]
빌사남 미간다 오늘은 대한민국에서
가장 호재가 많은 삼성동에 왔습니다
아 삼성동 상권은 2014년도 한전
부지가 매각되면서 되게 좀 각광을
받았던 거 같아요 그래서 원래 그
전까지는 강남역 상권이 되게
독보적이었던 그때 이제 2014년도에
매각이 되고 나서 주변에 개발
호재들이 좀 많이 생겨나면서 요즘
이제 얘기들은 강남역을 뛰어넘는
상권이 될 거다라는 얘기들이 좀
많습니다 한전 부지가 한 평당가로
쳤을 때 한 4억 정도 박이 됐어요
1대 가격을 다 올려 놓으면서 어
거기 주변에 이제 부동산 거래들이 좀
많이 됐습니다 어 삼성동 상권 같은
경우에는 제가 봤을 때 한 세 군데로
나눌 수 있어요 선능 인근 먹자 상권
그리고 도심공항 앞쪽의 상권 그다음에
이제 코엑스 상권 어 이렇게 세분류로
나눌 수 있는데이 세류 중에서 저는
가장 좋은 상권은 역시 이제 코엑스
상권이 제일 좋고 코엑스 상권 같은
경우에는 10대부터 연령층이 되게
다양합니다 그리고 이제 7일 상권이
그래서 주말에 사람이 더 많습니다
주변에 이제 호텔들도 많이 밀집되어
있고네 그러면서 외국인들 수요까지
많이 있습니다 그리고 여기 인근에
컨벤션 같이 행사도 많이 합니다
글로벌 행사도 많이 하면서 굉장히 좀
활발한 어 그런 상권이라고 보시면 될
거 같고 그리고 도신 공항 앞쪽 상권
같은 경우에는 아무래도 이제 직장인
수요가 좀 많이 있습니다 연령층이 좀
대체적으로 좀 되게 높고 연령층이 좀
높은 분들이 이용할 만한 그런 임차인
상권이 좀 많이 형성되어 있습니다
이제 그 선능 인근 상권 같은
경우에도 거기도 이제 직장인 수요가
좀 많이 있어 가지고 그거와 맞는
그런 상권이 좀 형성되 있습니다
그래서 첫 번째 선 능력 상권 두
번째 도심 공화 앞쪽 상권 같은
경우에나 주 5일 상권 코엑스 상권
같은 경우에는 주 72 상권이라고
보시면 될 거 같고이 코엑스는 뭐
아쿠아리움도 있고 메가박스도 있고
인근에 이제 뭐 백화점도 있고
해가지고 뭐 쇼핑 뭐 식다 볼 거리가
너무 많아서 주말에 오기 너무 좋아요
그래서 그 정도로 코엑 이쪽 은 제가
봤을 때 삼성동에서 제일 좋은 곳
같습니다 그리고 여기 이제 건너편에
gbc 있잖아요 그래서 이제 현대차가
이제 사옥이 올라가는데 설계도 아직
정해지지 않았습니다 그래서 되게
이슈가 많았어요 원래 이제 뭐
100층 이상으로 짓냐 마냐 그고
지금은 50층짜리 세계 동을 짓겠다고
설계안을 했는데 지금 또 이제
수정해서 어 이번에 또 변경을
한다라고 합니다 그래서 앞으로 좀
어떻게 될지 모르겠는데 어 그쪽
블록도 어찌됐든 좀 영향을 많이 받을
거기 때문에 여러분들이 지켜보시면
좋을 것 같습니다 삼성등 이번에 투자
사례는 저희가 예전에 중계했던 건물을
좀 소개해 드릴 건데 그게 이제
21년도 4m 정도 되는 도로에 좁은
도로에 있는 건물을 저희가 중계를
했었습니다 그래서 그때 당시에 대지가
한 40평 정도 됐었고 매입가는
60억 원에 매입을 했는데 일단은
건물이 그렇게 높지 않았어요 한 4
5층 정도 되는 규모의 건물이었는데
이거를 사자마자 일단 이것만 짓기에는
땅이 좀 너무 작았어요 도로도 너무
좋고 그래서 옆에 코너에 도로 에 좀
잘 접한 건물을 작업을 해서 그
건물까지 추가 매입을 했습니다 그래서
그 건물은 돼지가 한 50평 중반
정도 됐었는데 130억 원을
매입했어요 그래서 평당가로 봤을 때는
비싸긴 하지만 그 4m 도로에 있는
건물을 싸게 사 가지고 어찌됐든 이게
약간 업제 용으로 물타이 그러거든요
그래서 전체적인 금액을 봤을 때는
그래도 좀 저렴하게 어 매입한 그런
사례입니다 그래서 이거를 이렇게
매입했던 이유가 뭐냐면 어 가치를 더
올릴 수 있어요 그니까 이제 이면에
있 건물을 가치를 더 올릴 수 있고
그리고이 건물 같은 경우에는 용도
지역이 일반 상업 지역으로 돼
있습니다 좀 건물들 보면 한 4 5층
정도 되는 규모의 건물 같은 경우엔
용도 지역이 한 2종 아니면
3종이에요 근데 이거 같은 경우에는
일반 상업 지역으로 용적률이 800%
아지 가능합니다 그래서 2 3종 같은
경우에는 200에서 250%요
정도인데 거의 한네 배를 더 활용할
수 있는 거예요이 건물을 철거한
다음에 건물을 지상 14층까지 신축을
했습니다 그래서 용적률을 800%
거의 다 받았고 연면적으로 봤을 때는
거의 한 900평 정도 그래서 토지
활용도가 굉장히 높습니다 이거 같은
경우에는 활용도뿐만 아니라 임대
수익도 굉장히 높아지기 때문에
여러분들이 항상 건물을 살 때 땅의
용도 지역을 확인하셔야 돼요 그래서이
땅이 어떤 용도 지역을 가지고 있는지
그래서 나중에 건물을 가치를 올릴 수
있는지 그 부분을 파악하시면 좋을 것
같습니다 그래서이 삼성동 사례도이
평이라 땅에 토지 활용을 최대한 많이
한 어 그런 사례라고 보시면 될 거
맞습니다 삼성동은 총 여섯 개 블록
있습니다 근데 여기서 좀 다 똑같이
삼성동이라고 생각하시면 안 되고 다
블록마다 다르다라고 생각을 하셔야
돼요 일반적으로 상권이 그 길 건너서
잘 안 가거든요 그 그 대로를 넘기는
진짜 쉽지 않아요 그래서 좀이
블록마다 다 좀 차이가 있다라고
보시면 될 거 같고 그리고 저는
삼성동 중에서 가장 좋은 데는 여기
코엑스 잉글 삼성역 근처가 가장 좋을
거라고 생각을 하기 때문에 만약에
투자 상권에 투자를 하신다면 그
부분을 좀 생각 하시면 좋을 거 같고
개별적인 생각은 여기 이제 삼성형
1대가 되게 개발 호재가 되게
많잖아요 근데 그게 생기면 저는
삼성동의 별도의 상권이 생기긴 쉽지
않을 것 같아요 어 제가 말씀드렸던
세 군데 아니면은 뭐 gbc 근처
정도지 거기서 막 예를 들어서 뭐
삼성 중앙 역이라는 뭐 보문사역 그
위쪽이라 별도의 상권이 생기기 싶지
않을 겁니다 그래서 더 집중된 곳에
집중될 거 같아요 그래서 예를 들어서
뭐 롯데타워 같은 경우에도 사람들이
다 롯데타워 안에 있거든요 그래서
그것처럼 상권이 뭔가 별도로
생기기보다는 그냥 이제 성력 인근이
되게 더 발달할 것 같다 어 이런게
좀 제 개인적인 의견이고 근데 그
이쪽 이제 개발 허재가 워낙 많기
때문에 저는 오피스 수요가 더 많아질
거라고 생각해요 그리고 이제 gbc
관련된 그런 현 역사들이 주변에 좀
오피스를 많이 얻을 것으로 좀 예상을
합니다 그래서 여러분들이 삼성중
투자할 때 다 같이 뭐 호재 영향을
받는 좀 집중되는 곳에 집중이 된다
뭐 이렇게 보시면 될 거 같습니다네
그리고 삼성동 제가 미래 전망을 한
줄로 좀 요약하자면 앞으로 잘될 리만
남았다라는게 제 결론입니다 그래서
그만큼 되게 호재도 많고 영동대로
지하 호재도 있고 그 gbc 있고
기타 등등 여기 워낙 호재가 많아서
정말 삼성동의 천지 개벽할 거라는
거는 좀 의심의 여지가 없습니다 예
근데 여러분들이 앞으로 좀 보셔야
될게 일단은 시간이 오래 걸릴 거예요
그니까 지금 gbc 2014년도에
팔렸는데 아직 설계도 완성이 안
됐습니다 그래서 그 정도로 시간이
굉장히 좀 오래 소요될 여지가 있기
때문에 여러분들이 되게 장기 플랜으로
투자를 하셔야 된다라고 좀 생각이
들고 그리고 아까 말씀드렸던 것처럼
상권이 별도로 생기지 않기 때문에
이걸로 통해서 주변에 인근 상권이
엄청 활발이 될 거다라는 거는 확률은
좀 낮을 거라고 생각을 합니다 제
개인적인 생각에는 사람들이 다 지하로
다을 것으로 예상이 되기 때문에 어
별도의 상권이 생기긴 쉽지 않다 어
이런게 제 의견입니다데 어찌됐든
여기가 이제 개발호재가 워낙 많기
때문에 어 그와 관련된 그런
오피스라는 뭐 호텔이라 뭐 기타 이런
것들이 들어올 여지가 워낙 많기
때문에 앞으로 삼성동을 좀 계속
지켜보시면 좋을 것 같습니다 그리고
거기 앞에 보면 이렇게 강남스타일
동상도 있고 되게 좀 외국인
관광객들이 뭔가 사진 찍기 좋게 좀
만들어 놨어요 그러면서 한국에서 꼭
와야 될 만한 어 그런 장소로 앞으로
좀 되지 않을까네 그렇게 생각하고
있습니다 오늘은 인프라의 성지
삼성동에 대해서 알아보았습니다 진짜
모든게 다 갖춰진 그런 상권이고
앞으로 호재도 저는 대한민국에서 가장
많은 곳이라고 생각하기 때문에
여러분들 삼성동 계속 좀 지켜보시면
좋을 것 같고 사남이 간다 이렇게
계속 좀 답사하면서 그 지역에
상권이라는 이런 거 좀 분석해 드리고
있으니까 지금 구독자 여러분들이
궁금해하시는 그런 상권이라는 이런게
있다라고 하시면 댓글 남겨 주시면 어
제가 또 직접 찾아가서 상권
분석이라는 뭐 부동산 분석이라는 이런
거를 해 드리도록 하겠습니다 어이
영상이 마음에 드셨다면 구독과 좋아요
어 눌러 주시고 다음 시간에 뵙도록
하겠습니다 리딩은
사나네 말 하느라고 못 먹었어
[음악]